foreign
people welcome to the Honest Trailer
commentary for Pinocchio Pinocchio
Pinocchio that's right it's like body's
body
but with Pinocchio very similar very
similar uh we've all been displaced uh
by various holiday things uh not me not
you yeah
dug in like a tick you can't get rid of
him I'll let you we don't it's already
on holiday
with my candles you could do that from
anywhere happy Hanukkah to everyone once
again to Merry Christmas and whatever
else you celebrate uh you're all welcome
here as is every Pinocchio movie we
clearly did not have any standards when
we started watching these
um I can't believe it I just want to
talk about the Paulie Shore one that's
the only one I only want to talk about
the Polish or one for the rest of my
life can I make a confession as
ridiculous as the Paulie Shore one is I
think I I think I I think the hated most
hated one is the Disney song of course
yeah that one's actually more evil but I
I didn't mind the partial one as much I
thought it was funnier than most
comedies well it's because with the poly
Shore one you go in going oh Paulie
Shores in this but what's the Met kiss
you you have an expectation right it's
together that's why it's more evil it
hurts my soul more to see what what Tom
Hanks and Bob's mechis have been reduced
to yeah the other one is just like what
if the Pinocchio story wasn't about
anything that Pinocchio was about what
if it was a sort of a crime Thriller
behind the scenes at a circus but that's
like okay you're doing your own thing
that's a hook yeah they certainly were
uh it just makes me want to watch not
even a Blue Fairy like that's it's crazy
but it's even the kind of because there
is like a magical girl with blue hair
yeah or you could tell they were like
huh yeah hi get it but it's like no it's
still bad it's not enough like Pinocchio
to Warrant being Pinocchio like I don't
mind changing it I'm not a Pinocchio
purist folks like do what you want with
the story I'll just say like like you
you need at least three elements of
Pinocchio to make this Pinocchio and
then do your own thing but this is like
he's maybe what like if you get very
close to the puppet's face you can see
that they put texture to make them look
wood otherwise these are just about a
boy and his horse yeah he had his
blusher is fantastic whoever loses his
cheeks a little apple cheeked boy yes
there is a bit at the end where he's
I'm a real boy now
um
[Applause]
and like you can't they they didn't
change the animation enough their
texture settings were not clear enough
for them to even visually you have to
have polish or yell I'm a real boy
because otherwise you couldn't tell no
you just ran away yeah when do I get to
go out of my uh do I get it
but I I found it bad in a very
entertaining way whereas the other ones
were just well but the it's an echix one
was bad and the camera Del Toro one is
great um like so yeah we're gonna watch
we're gonna watch honest trailer for all
of them answer your questions so so put
those in the chat and I'm sure we have a
deleted scene or two plus we'll tease
you with next week's honest trailer
which is that we're on vacation
it's go watch Avatar again because we're
let's go yeah I don't watch it we'll
talk about it I watched white Avatar oh
I meant go watch our avatar on his
trailer oh yeah
Avatar of the water babies please
Slippery When Wet
um
let's start with uh every Pinocchio and
we'll go from there let's watch the
trailer
[Music]
in a year where comic book movies are
starting to fade no one wants to see
dramas and our most beloved celebrities
can't get people into theaters Hollywood
has decided to repurpose the same 19th
century public domain Italian novel
three different times in one calendar
year with let's say varying results
I can't wait to go to school and learn
what all this stuff is I don't want to
be one of a kind
I want to be like everyone else
oh man and the fact that they don't drop
the voice in until like 15 minutes until
oh yeah they
they really they make your way
yeah and then I wait for the shore you
get Tom Kenny and John hater right away
you should also add Valley Shores
Pinocchio he he does not have a Cricket
friend in this one because as I
mentioned playing a little fast and
loose with the Pinocchio story so he's
got a a talking horse friend who is
Napoleon Dynamite and then Geppetto is
SpongeBob I don't I didn't catch that
for a while but Tom it's just like it
feels like a waste of Tom Kenny but you
go cash that check it's a total waste of
time getting it also he like their take
on Geppetto everybody's take a Geppetto
all three movies are like crushed
poisoned by loneliness at death's door
like a pathetic old man yeah like
they're sure he's he's not doing well in
any of these but I think the the
Pinocchio a true story version he's he's
like he seems suicidal to me like when
Pinocchio leaves they get Tom Kenny a
line where he's like oh somehow I'll
carry On Without You Pinocchio you are
the only thing I love and it's like
Jesus is heavy
I do think that Tom Hanks one is a
little I think the Tom x one is like
that's a man whose life is flashing
before yes there's one line in the Tom
Hanks one he when he's keep he's figured
out Pinocchio has gone missing and he's
gonna go look for him and he's Gathering
of course you would bring your cat and
your goldfish with you on your side uh
and he they drop one line where he's
like oh I haven't actually left the shop
since uh everyone's like like he hasn't
been outside in years yeah I kind of
gloss over it they don't really Linger
on that beat
[Music]
the fact that there's just three
pinocchios this year I've always been
pitching this I guess I'm just gonna
have to write it myself is is the public
domain Avengers movie where it's like I
guess they did that with League of
Extraordinary too yeah yeah really but
like let's do it like yeah that's a
Shrek I mean Shrek has Pinocchio in it
and the you know gingerbread man and all
like all the the public domain fairy
tales right you get Pinocchio Robin Hood
King Arthur Frankenstein's monster
Dracula like they you could you could
team those people up we do watch
yourself the universe we do a King
Arthur whatever you were to have we're
about he can't carry he's like the Hulk
he can't carry his own movie but but
it's the round table I think Arthur's
one of those fascinating things like
everybody knows King Arthur the name
Lance like some of it they can name some
of the knights Camelot but I don't think
people actually like care about the
story those King Arthur the actual
Legends and myths most people don't that
could do you know story like like his
his wife cheated on him with Lancelot
they went to look for the Holy Grail and
most people only know that because of
Monty Python yeah the Green Knight he's
in the green night right well sir that
one in the Green Knight is is a epic
poem about a character from The King
Arthur cycle but it's not really like
you wouldn't make that in a King Arthur
movie right the best one I ever read was
a bodice ripper when I was like 14 and
it was like oh
I will quote it but no no no please do
but Lance a lot Mansel he lances a lot
he laughs a lot I feel like this is what
we always get to do like first night and
that King Arthur was it like Charlie
Hunnam like it's always like oh King
Arthur right what what happens again
yeah I think I don't know the sad thing
is like good and Noble Kings or like
inherently uninteresting characters so
you have to be like what was the real
story and give me the taste this yeah
what he really was was uh he was
involved in a circus that was secretly
stealing from people as they were
watching and they'll sing about it soon
let's keep watching the Pinocchio
trailer but he do Pinocchio movie
four generations audiences fell in love
with Pinocchio a puppet who learns to be
honest and Brave on his way to becoming
a real boy but what if that wasn't the
true story and it was really a crime
drama about a gang of Thieves
infiltrating a circus I'll tell the
whole truth about what you really doing
and then every one of you will go to
jail where the Blue Fairy was actually
the Scarlet Witch Jiminy Cricket was a
horse with weird put Downs I find his
appearance rather dull you could have
made a more joyful and intelligent
puppet and Pinocchio was a gasified
horse dancer
[Music]
[Applause]
why
the only thing they love more than horse
dancing is dash cam videos kids movies
are just built different over there I
will whip you to death no
I will kill you too with my bare hands I
suppose I I'm wondering wondering if
that was a translation stuff I think
they translate it literally and or they
just tried to do anything they could to
match the lips but like you don't need
to do that it's okay I feel like there
were a lot of scenes where it's just
characters clearly exasperated with each
other like
yeah they're just doing a lot of that
and so the dialogue just becomes these
constant like that's all the characters
are saying to each other for the whole
story it's like you nincompoops I told
you to go that way I just assumed that
it was all put through Google like
translate and like that was what they
had and that's what they went with me
because it is an actual job where people
with Talent will be like oh no but don't
you want to like invoke the actual
spirituality yeah it's like oh no you
don't want to do any of that you just
want the words okay fine Pauly Shore
will cover this it's very fantastic
actor yeah I was definitely wondering
how much of this is like how much of
this is the original as written story
and how much of this is like a a quick
and dirty English translator job you
know like somebody probably had this in
three other movie animated movies on
their desk that day and like crank these
out man yeah I was looking into this and
at the beginning of the year
um Holly Shores Pinocchio was a huge
like Tick Tock sensation like people
were like kids what is this voice oh my
God because they were not around they
don't know the words they don't know
that you have to wheeze the juice
We are failing our children I mean you
did not know about the juice we say
we're old enough to wheeze the juice but
even like a leaning tower of chisa they
don't even know about it so it'd be
weird if we were like because a lot of
the references are so nice like would
biodome even make sense today if you
don't even it's not only you don't
remember Pauly Shore but remember the
bio Dome like that whole concept would
be so weird like what is it you know
it's that movie that stars Justin
Bieber's wife's dad
you know that one you know that one
um hell yeah uh that's a whole other
side track we won't get we don't go down
the Baldwin
holesome that's one for us yeah I think
the honest Trail there will be a 2023
bio Dome and like in the Army now or
son-in-law or something we don't need to
go crazy
[Laughter]
memorized keep going experience a film
that looks almost as good
you know who's in biodome
is
um Roger Clinton Bill Clinton's brother
yeah yes that's true that's true and he
was like a musician and he has like a
random like lingering shot of like him
singing a song and has never really
mentioned again you're like why is that
because he was he was kind of like the
hunter Biden of his day like every
president has like one family member
that just becomes like famously um like
a screw-up or whatever every president
has a fail brother right and that it's
hard to compare when your brother's the
president you're gonna look like a
screw-up no matter what but yeah but
yeah especially the right that was his
like it was kind of a joke like oh the
the president's like you know Pauly
shore-esque Brothers gonna be in biodome
yeah again a 90s only right like if
you're coming in as a Zoomer you're like
what what is this you just said a bunch
of words
is an excellent source of photosynthesis
my head
yeah good find Daniel I love them with
an All-Star cast of the best voice
Talent currently on Cameo
um
who transforms his voice chameleon-like
into that of 90s icon Pauly Shore
when can I leave to be on my own I want
to meet other people
anything in my life I want it just a
little behind me
the original version that we pulled of
this had like a
non-celebrity English and you're the
only one who watched that one because I
watched the podcast yes that was the
original one that was said and I watched
it and uh for a while I was like
credit where it's due to John hater and
polish or they have changed their voice
they're doing voices they're not just
being themselves and then we sent an
email that was like hey there's a
different English language track with
Paulie short here's the real one and I
watched it and it's like props to polish
your generator they did not do a voice
at all they went with their natural
speaking voice it probably was the first
time they've read any of these lines
tried to sound like a horse let's keep
playing you'll hear it it's like John
hater who actually Alters his voice
probably out of embarrassment
I knew it all along and SpongeBob Legend
Tom Kenny as Geppetto who really has
nothing to be embarrassed about I mean
it's not like he was the voice of skids
and Transformers 2. oh that that's old
school yo that that's like that's the
sabatonian wait he was Barnacles so if
you're looking for a take on Pinocchio
different than what you're used to enjoy
the only version where his dad is a
horse you want me to be your father just
say yes I probably pause here pause we
need to talk about this this is not a
one I want to talk about horse Dad yeah
this is not a one-off joke this is a
theme that runs through the entire movie
Pinocchio begs the horse to be his feet
he clearly has a father he could go home
to his father anytime but he's like I
don't like that father I want this horse
to be my mother the horse at first is
like I don't want the job
also I'm a horse and you're a wooden
puppet uh but no eventually that becomes
like he starts referring to him as my
son and they it's a whole Arc it seems
to be like um kind of like a stage dad
that he's looking for because he needs
him to sign a con to like sign away his
life on a contract Colonel he's also his
Colonel Tom Parker also he's also it's
been planning the ultimate Snow Job yeah
I need you to be my dad
[Music]
the immersion from me of um this one and
the and the zemeckis one whereas
everybody is freaking out about a wooden
boy
um but talking animals are just par for
the course like a talking how how far
how strange can a wooden puppet be how
ostracized can you be for being that
when like a squirrel and a horse and a
pig and a fox are all like uh cracking
Chris Pine jokes the the Disney one is
so crazy with this where it's like
because because uh Lorraine Bracco is a
is a toxic Eagle but humans thinking
about it yeah humans can't hear Karen
Hill they they can they can hear but the
but there's a fox
Keegan Michael key is a human-sized Fox
and it seems like everybody can hear him
talk and we'll get there but why is the
cat animated anyway anyway let's keep
going yeah we'll get there it's a it's a
huge difference this is my favorite line
of the movies one of the clowns I know
was told by another clown that man is a
fairy who lives by a mountain and
everyone is strapped at all times let me
make a couple holes in this puppet
you think I'm scared of your guns you
want to be my ticket out of here
what did I say enough with the shooting
already but hey at least the songs are
also in the movie
been deceived as well and Manziel foco
is their boss
I love this I do not understand we did
not edit like this is what the song
sounds like it is it sounds like people
just learned what music was and decided
to try it for themselves well what I
love is we the audience are learning
this concurrently with Pinocchio and
with the circus audience of like what
kind of scheme and crimes they were
pulling throughout the movie like they
reveal actual crucial information
through this song it's like yeah by the
way this whole circus has been a front
so that they can sneak into your house
while you're at the Circle right like
the idea the crime is happening right
now yeah so you could instead of doing
the choreographed song you could have
been like hey they're like in your house
like seeing your stuff
yeah it seems like it's a very confusing
plan like it takes the whole movie for
them to even reveal like they put on a
circus and then while the entire Village
goes to see the circus they go into the
village and like Rob everybody you're
really relying on the circus being a
huge draw because if you even hacked the
town stays behind they're gonna be like
well look at that they're robbing the
house across the street aren't those
aren't isn't that the cat and the fox
who are just performing at the circuit
so it's like it's a terrible plan right
oh Rob just go rob places you don't need
to do this whole circus bit it's very
elaborate it's one of those things where
it's like do you just just admit that
you like being in a circus yeah
you don't have to pretend to be a crime
game
totally
um yeah keep going
NP no man
from director Robert zemeckis who's
moved around time into The Uncanny
Valley comes a movie so aware of its own
crappiness they basically rub your face
in it in a film destined to slide
quietly down the end of a Disney plus
Sub menu where it will slowly run away
into the obscurity it so richly deserves
and not just an accent an entrepreneur
nay an influencer no turn on Disney plus
best argument for adding a playback
speed option in a film that's only worth
watching to check in on how many holes
long covet has put into Tom Hanks brain
why because he likes you
as he turns Geppetto into the biggest
2022 boy lover since his take on the
colonel now turn around let me get a
look at it oh Marianne
my boy my boy bumming around a green
screened hellscape singing Nonsense to
nobody
smoked holy Smoky oh indeed can you
believe Chad Hanks had a better year
than his dad big up the whole island
massive it's her boy
ready to begin with this it's really if
you really want like your heart to break
actually picture Tom Hanks in that in a
green room dancing around in his night
yeah dressed like Uncle Charlie from
from Willy Wonka like with nobody else
set that day and Bobby's Mecca like all
right Tom let's do it one more time like
that's it's the set he says he yells cut
and then he just like has like a dry
coughing spell it's just covered why why
and like there's there's that big when
he's in the boat where it's just like it
was just him and like this green
background like this little boat that
these guys are moving back and forth
It's so like remember Castaway like yeah
that was good don't do this to National
Treasure Tom holy Smokey yeah holy Smoky
it is like 40 minutes of the movie we're
just in that one room with him like that
it's a the prologue on this thing is and
absolutely endless yeah he's just there
making like counterfeit Disney clocks
that he refuses to sell I guess he can
he be arrested
um it's a really licensing problem
really sad Geppetto
um and poor Tom yeah Tom Hanks I mean
long like you can skip some of it you
have a narrator there's a cricket
telling us everything that happens just
just get to it man yeah he's entered
that um Pacino
zone or like not Bruce Willis quite yet
um for the but like where Tom Hanks like
she seemed to be behind them
I mean what's that smell
he's not like he's not doing that like
the the Nicholson De Niro Pacino thing
where you just like start taking roles
and like play the same guy over and over
again because that's what people want
like two quick credits but he kind of is
this year no but two is great and it's
so weird it was nothing like they're
they're not similar they're just it's
just bad like yeah like I don't feel
like he's doing the same thing every
time he's doing the same thing as the
kernel in this one there's a lot of
similarities between the colonel and
Geppetto
no one who was in Elvis could let it go
like Austin's still doing still doing
the voice yeah yeah Tom is still doing
the stories no he's gonna be like oh boy
but let's have a let's have a Chris not
five
I'm using the weirding way
um and yeah props to um uh Joseph
Gordon-Levitt for his no what how dare
you no props to Joseph Gordon is he
wearing the skin of another Cricket over
his face
he's Jiminy oh got it okay yeah that's
what I meant oh yeah well this is the
real story of the book yeah he's doing
like a a diet goofy um it's like the you
know what it reminded me of is like the
the in Goofy Movie the Lester's possum
part characters where it's like that
kind of like hey welcome you know like
that kind of like wild crazy hick yes I
don't know why no I got me a new suit
yeah it's like you're Italian Robin yeah
are you an Italian Cricket how did you
get here from Tennessee and then the the
well that's true to the original I guess
is that the the kids are from Brooklyn
when they get to Pleasure Island um
let's keep going so prepare for a
Pinocchio that's bad in all the most
boring ways I have some very good
garments for you with the same beats as
the original with all the edges sanded
off
full of wink nudge comedy that's out of
date before the movie even came out we
need a stage name Chris Pine nah it
never work Timeless an animation that
looks like you told an AI about a wooden
boy then pulled the plug before it
finished rendering at least when Walt
put his animators in the Sweatshop they
made Cinderella modernity socks that's
right
he's been passionate about making for so
long cute swear it featured a child in
World War II sympathetic monsters evil
humans and a sea creature that someone
tries to have sex with no well four out
of five ain't bad put the kids to bed
for a Pinocchio story that truly
considers the implications of being a
soulless piece of wood that will never
take the place of a sad old man's
murdered child that makes our childlike
hero die repeatedly you will die many
many times
swaps Pleasure Island for a fascist
Military Academy and ends with him
bearing the only people he ever loved
that's so relentlessly Grim all the best
jokes are about Nazi salutes gone wrong
[Music]
I think hilarious so if you want
there's not much to talk about this is a
great movie it's so good it's so good
um max was asking me uh should I watch
it with my four-year-old and I was like
no no I'm not mad
we talk about how Grim it is it is like
okay for it's not like R-rated like no
no no you'd have to explain fashion
if you're ready if you're ready to
explain Hitler like look when you get to
the Hitler age that's when you can show
them what is the Hitler age Danielle I
believe it's grade six so when you get
when you get to Hitler your class
project yeah yeah that's when you can
start explaining okay this Pinocchio I
mean if it's 1938 all ages but in 2022
you know I think you could say like 12
13. yeah what could make sure my oma
wasn't here but she's uh she's uh lower
down
but you know when you get to the Hitler
ages that's when you can bring them in
Pinocchio for Hitler ages and up I think
is the is the tagline for this one
um fantastic but you can watch you can
watch it without kids it's that good yes
um it's a it's a real work of prayer so
holy Smoky yeah holy Smoky things holy
Smoky oh at any point no one says
pistols there's none of that it's not a
lot of there's less gun play in the one
that is explicitly about Mussolini's
rice yeah yeah actually
uh he does get ganked a few times but
we'll we'll keep going there's some
explosions it's not violence free but
on 2022 Pinocchio movie that was
actually good thanks to the always great
gdt and a co-director who's done
claymation for so long he worked on the
California Raisins watch the world
immensely crafted with a Bittersweet
message about retaining your humanity
and a standout performance from
Christoph Waltz as a circus freak who
spanks his monkey you have any idea
nobody wanted you I saved you Christophe
Watson fascist Europeans seem a better
combo
morning wood uh pause um I don't know if
I ever told you guys about this but um I
saw Christoph Waltz once in our old
office
like an office before this one he goes
to he goes to one of the doctors there
were so many doctors yeah I was I used
to see a lot of people getting bbls
there and I was like really okay so yeah
you see a lot of people I'm not saying
Kristoff next time you see Kristoff do a
spin and you see that that juicy dumper
it nipped and tucked uh one time I saw
my greatest celebrity sighting at that
office was uh the guy who played Mickey
Kramer's friend on Seinfeld you guys
remember Mickey from no I remember
Mickey had like he's like a little
person he's got a beard they were like
actors he's been in a ton of stuff he's
a really good actor yeah that was an
exciting uh celebrity Danny Woodburn
okay there you go Danny Woodburn I've
seen this guy in a million places oh
yeah he's like one of those uh yeah you
guys know his face like
you'll see you'll recognize
awesome that's a good sighting that's it
that's awesome like Mickey from Seinfeld
like oh yeah also if you've never seen a
woman try to get into an Uber not using
her ass to sit down
well because you can't sit when you get
a baby yeah
you don't want to know you can't sit for
like two minutes it should just go like
like tummy down in the background
yeah you got to kind of plank it dude
you never see the skateboarding just
Marty McDonald I saw this a few times
where yeah it's obvious that you're just
like you can't okay because they're
they're not they're not purely like
planking into the car but they're trying
to like ease in and then you can't sit
on the new goods for like two months so
that's okay
like like a human would you got a kind
of ease your way in yeah yeah wow but
when you get to sell you know weight
loss tea on Instagram look when you get
that donkey donkey it's
we were either gonna fix the studio or
we were all gonna get BBS
and which shows the studio for you for
you right for you
oh man there should be a Pinocchio but
it's just about like getting a real ass
um because he's a real boy from the very
beginning he just wants a badonkadonk
yeah or I'd say like Geppetto has this
big wooden butt that he just wishes was
real
um that's a whole other story all right
keep going
because wow the pee hole goes deep the
70s Soviet versions the TV mini-series
with Bob Hoskins that just made
Pinocchio real boy the whole time to cut
costs the one where Seinfeld crosses
over with The Drew Carey Show the most
90s version possible the most 2000s
version possible the one where an adult
man plays Pinocchio the one where the
same adult man now plays Geppetto but
Pinocchio is somehow even creepier the
up and coming dark and gritty video game
live PJ Spader and strings but now I'm
free and the Shrek version which
probably wins by default I am wearing
ladies underwear
are you
I am not it looks like you most
certainly am oh
every 2022 Pinocchio movie
when somebody calls themselves honest
they ain't oh no they're on to us quick
everyone scram yeah let's set up our
circus in the new town
we've already robbed all of these people
there were more pinocchios we could have
listed uh so many pinocchios uh what was
there was another one that was
interesting oh AI was a funny one
someone pointed out yeah it was a good
one I was trying to explain that one uh
the other day and I was like I got
nothing I'm like really trying to uh
explain well because you can very
clearly see when uh Spielberg was like
rest in peace but this is my movie now
like you know when he took over on AI
it's a little interesting though because
if you go read some of the stuff that
reads very spielbergy was that was
actually like Kubrick was in a kind of a
saccharine place when he who wrote this
outline so there are some of those
elements that you feel like well that's
got to be Steve yeah and then it was
actually Stan so it's a it's a it's an
interesting that ending is all Spielberg
right the like distant future where yes
I I believe so but it has to be I think
Kubrick's version may have left I'm sure
he had a four hour movie of AI
let us know we'll wait
go on yeah it's explicit in AI that I
believe there is a Blue Fairy reference
or two like they do kind of put a point
on it no no there is a moment where you
and me feels like okay this is where
this movie ends and when Spielberg's
movie begins
there's like a moment well thank you all
for watching
um like And subscribe it's your last
chance in 2022. no no it's not you can
keep doing that for for weeks but we
won't be here telling you live to do the
same yeah
um it's our last time to yell at you to
do it you'll have to take it yeah
if you haven't already but uh it'd be
it'd be be fun get get your loved ones
the gift that lasts a lifetime was a
subscription to a free YouTube channel
um does it come with an nft are we doing
that yet or no one day we should yeah we
need to do it instead
apparently you can do a BBL in an nft
and it looks amazing yeah
okay we should do nfts of all of us with
bbls and then we can get wow what would
we all look like yeah well I don't need
one but good for you
but if it was bigger yeah no you can
always go big I couldn't fit through a
door if it was bigger have you seen this
dump truck now it's an nft
uh do you have any outtakes
with all the answers
[Music]
the naughty kids drink root beer what
are they Amish
take it out of here
drop it I say enough with the shooting
already When You Wish Apollo
laughs
Pinocchio a rue story
Drake
Guillermo del Toro's cabinet of wooden
monstrosities
I knows who killed me
I guess that's it well there you go I
like that yeah why is the root beer
animated like there's some decisions in
that Disney Pinocchio where it's like
crazy
the cat cats are cute on their own you
don't need a fake cat It's just sad
Pleasure Island it seems like Luke Evans
is there and there's a real kid playing
lamp wick and like the boat is real and
the mugs are real but the root beer
inside the mugs is digital what yeah I
didn't want to have to like reason like
they were afraid of spills or something
like I think so oh my God they could
save money they didn't have to hire a
root beer continuity person yeah like
yeah yeah and the cat I think they just
maybe the cat was just they wanted the
full they wanted Tom Hanks fully
isolated they didn't want anything to
give him warmth or comfort so that
wouldn't even give him okay also think
about trying to Wrangle for all the
stuff Tom Hanks has to be doing in that
little green room it'd be hard with a
kitten like I I get I get practicality
there and then they made it look like an
uncanny an uncaddy thing is the kid is
making facial reactions it's just big
for a real cat Yeah Yeah well yeah and
you couldn't possibly like disrupt all
of the moments of Tom playing with his
real doll
it's like Tom and the Real Girl
of just Tom Hanks in this green room
talking to nobody like it's so long it
takes so long for Patoka to go to school
my God and it's only a 90 minute movie
but it feels like it lasts forever
forever ever uh all right onto the Q a
uh Bruins fan 1144 in the original story
he killed Jimny Cricket his feet were
burned off and he was hanged uh which
Disney adaptation shocked you the most
by the darkness of the source material
the feet on fire thing plays into a lot
of these the the semicus one includes
that and then yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean
Little Mermaid like a little mermaid oh
and I've seen because they there's a
really good
um my folks thinking that this was going
to be uh The Little Mermaid that I fell
in love with when I was a kid got me the
anime one where it's just like uh uh
full frontal nudity and it's the full
like oh she becomes bubbles in the water
and it's really sad uh so that was the
one that I had on home movie and I'm
gonna say it is actually really good
um yeah I think it's it's Hunchback to
me like the original Victor Hugo novel
Hunchback of Notre Dame is really messed
up I mean great but really dark and to
take to I like that movie but to take
that even the the Disney version is
pretty Hellfire sounds real dark but
like to read that book it'd be like this
could be an animated film is a real like
leap of imagination like more more
credit to them it is one of those things
with like oh things are getting really
dark I don't know Danny DeVito say
something that's Hercules this one is
the Jason Alexander uh as a funny
gargoyle gargoyles yeah it just confused
the two of them yeah
I don't know if you guys have seen how
James mangled mocks Indy five Trolls but
if so what director do you wish did the
same uh yeah
they're both on a real tear where
they're just like
shooting down online rumors and talking
crap to trolls and just generally being
like I'm sick of how
angry and unpleasant a lot of the
internet social media banter is around
my upcoming projects that are they're
really kind of bringing the fight to the
trolls instead of just signing and
taking it well and most of it is also
like hey you could not like it but you
don't get to lie right I mean a lot of
what Mangold has been doing is there's
all these reports about reshooting the
ending and he's like all that's
overblown nobody's getting it right like
movies on track shut up nerds and it's
sort of the similar kind of like you
know James Gunn had that post the other
day where he's like look Peter saffron
and I knew when we took this job that
there's going to be a lot of anger and
complaining online and a lot of people
are going to be attacking us and we're
just blocking that out of our minds and
focusing on the work
I'd save more power to them yeah more
power to them I I it's good for them for
for clapping back but to me the true
Mark of success and and what I would do
uh had I any uh cachet in the film
industry would be to never go on Twitter
again I think that like that is to me
that's the mark of if you've made it is
you don't have to talk to them but good
for them you know if you're if you're in
Lily Allen and you want to spend all
morning this morning and last night
defending NEPA babies oh no oh no I'll
send you the tweets
Bono's daughter tweeted like she didn't
even get into the nepo babies article
I'm like that's got to be tough if
you're a nepo baby but you're not big
enough to be in the nepo baby expose
like I do feel for those I saw that yeah
I mean I saw the tweets about it and
they were like they called out chalamet
because his uncle made Gremlins 2 or
something like that was it there was
something's uncle is Joe Dante no no it
was was it was so like like if your
uncle made a movie in the 80s I don't
think that makes you attention like if
your uncle made Pinocchio a true story
or something like that yeah is this how
I okay
let's move on to another question
uh Adam Halbert was anyone aware that
Cate Blanchette was the voice of the
monkey in the Del Toro movie yes we were
it's amazing you can tell there is a
point where the monkey starts doing
puppet voices like the monkey could
speak as long as it's portraying a
marionette character and those sound
like Cate Blanchett like otherwise she's
just making monkey noises also look Cape
blanchett's having a whole voice year
because she was just in what Avatar like
she's having like a whole thing yeah
yeah
um that was good for her what a year for
her actually I actually thought it was
Lydia tar at first and then I was like
oh no that's not the real Lydia tar
that's just K-pop yeah
so I guess chalamet's grandfather uh
wrote car 54 Where Are You the TV series
there's a few other pilots and like TV
episodes from the 60s I don't think that
uh that's not a lot of juice
it's all relative to the amount of juice
you know like if you're a guestry
Spielberg dad's got a ton of juice
now you have the juice
if you wrote the thing that the dude
from The Munsters is like second most
famous for you don't get to call
yourself a Napa baby like that's not
um but this will be our new show is who
it is
standard I could literally talk about
this for hours you know so just why are
we pretending like this is somehow like
a new trend it's like yeah there's a lot
of like a lot of the people that you
just think of as celebrities were
actually the children of other if
Barrymore
um
all right Matan valenski says uh does
nobody remember that RDJ also has a
Pinocchio in the works yes this is
everyone's passion project we're not
entirely sure why everyone's obsessed
with this one story right because it's
not even it's one of those stories where
it's like four beats everyone knows and
you kind of can't do the story without
some of those beats and it's just like
we we know them already like what what
are you gonna bring to the table that's
new yeah he also has uh follows up with
can you talk about the upcoming Disney
Live Action Peter Pan by David Lowry the
JPEG and Iger didn't think deserve the
theater I haven't seen or heard anything
about it but I'm sure it doesn't yeah I
mean there's no I'm sure it does not
there's no reason to make it anymore
stop making Peter Pan
he's the guy who did the Green Knight he
did that Pete's Dragon adaptation that's
actually really good like the fact that
he did a ghost story uh with Rooney Mara
hi he's he's pretty good like if he
wants to do it I feel like
there's got to be some compelling thing
there you know I don't know I was gonna
say Dave wow you don't want to say hook
um I think that uh yeah uh this is a
good one from gym one I've asked Santa
for a Demolition Man trailer for his
30th Anniversary when is the 30th
Anniversary because we will 100 do that
um I think it was this year wasn't it oh
Crown 93 so it's next year all right
October 8th 1993 was the release date of
the original demolition get your
peroxide ready we're all dying our hair
blonde yeah get your get ready for the
shells
um 2023 let's do it I love that movie
mellow greetings everybody yeah
uh take me to Taco Bell baby
I think that's it should we stop talking
or should we keep should we do one more
I'm gonna do one more why not yeah
um let's see let's see uh here's an
open-ended one from Scare shark do you
think movie theaters are dying and if
they're dying what do you think is the
future of movies I saw that one
uh I was actually in a movie theater the
other day and I held it as a gasped in
my arms and I said don't leave me
I don't think movies are I don't think
movie theaters are gonna die completely
I think that we're it's one of those
it's like a record store thing you know
like
every town used to have two or three
music stores it was just like a kind of
thing that was around now maybe your
town has like one cool one that
everybody goes you know it's just like
there's less and I think that it's gonna
be that like there used to be a time
where there were enough people go to
movies where every city had like dozens
of theaters with 12 screens each and it
was this huge thing there's gonna be
fewer but I I don't think it's gonna
totally go away I also think we might
morph into a
theaters if they've got a bunch of
screens not all of them are showing
brand new things like like Nostalgia
Revival screenings are such a huge thing
I feel like if you had 12 screens it
would make sense to put like new stuff
on six and then run Roger Rabbit and you
know Star Wars and like when you know
older stuff people might want to come
see and make more of a you know
[Music]
it's wild because uh when I went to go
see what Avatar
um like people in my family were like
well how much was that and I was like no
I got that for free because I'm on a
list and I was like explaining AMC a
list to folks and they like
didn't know what it was and I was like
this is like the biggest lick that you
could ever
do being able to see like you know three
movies a week and blah blah blah blah so
like go do that that's the kind of stuff
that's gonna like the reason why it's so
cheap is because they want you in the
theater so that you can you know buy the
popcorn buy the popcorn get the hot dog
we're seeing habits change like there
there was just a tweet that was talking
about
um violent night is doing better than
like any of the big Oscar hopeful movies
in theaters right now like an outgrows
tar and banshees of inner Sharon and
fablemans and like every single one all
put together violent night the one with
uh you know David Harbor yeah die hard
and the menu that box Searchlight one
that came out that's like the biggest
Indie release of like it's like it's
shifting and I think that that that
seems apocalyptic when it's happening
but I don't know if it I don't know if
it is apocalyptic I think there is still
an audience for art films just maybe not
in big movie theaters in every city and
I think that you know people still want
to go see movies they just maybe don't
want to go see the kinds of movies we're
releasing in theaters and all of that's
going to happen yeah but I don't think
it's going to be no more movie theaters
in 10 years like ever again but there's
just going to be a lot of them are going
to close and like I don't know what you
feel that real estate with except laser
tag so I'm just gonna be buying up a lot
of defunct movie theaters
VR experience VR spas and um and yeah uh
suspense series I think Spirit Halloween
dispensary Spirit Halloween's and
dispensaries and and combo dispensaries
slash Spirit Halloween
places for places for ladies to get
their eyebrows bladed yeah threading and
blading yes yes Good Times uh well
that's a wrap on our 2022 I think uh we
saved movies once again
um
in order we'll be back in the new year
with
um a film that's uh I'll say it's a
pretty easy mystery for you to solve for
what we're gonna start the year with
um and then we're gonna wakanda on to
the next one after that
so that's what gave you since we're gone
for two weeks those are your next two
yeah you guys are good for like late
January now yeah yeah so no more clues
um
you're gonna spend a couple weeks
cracking those uh yeah like the Zodiac
Killer over here so yeah start cracking
that Cipher and and let me know what you
think what you it's not what you think
it's what you think
um but thank you thank you to everyone
watching and I hope you have a happy
safe holidays and uh that's all bye for
now
[Music]
thank you
[Music]